it's the same thing I'm going to go to
neutral pressure and I'm going to rotate
so I catch on the back foot that's where
the rotation happens and you're already
off okay he's going to come back again
and I'm going to do this
one so again weido ten con boom back
again uh make it a little more
dynamic
boom
boom so if you move where you can see
what I'm doing on his shoulder pressure
here's his shoulder pressure okay and
I'm slightly off angle and I'm rotating
it you see and then I get to the other
side he comes
back okay and I'm going to do
it this way
come back here he
is okay I step out this is EO foot
maneuver this
way
[Music]
again
okay so again slow there's two
pressures
catch rotate you see they're Bas I'm
just exaggerating the shoulders now if
you do it with your hip okay and then
when it comes back around you're going
to do it
again here okay wait with your
quad
[Music]
it's not that I'm getting out of the way
we're not doing that right now feel it
turn
it okay try it okay so here's the catch
okay and then if I stay here if I keep
this
relationship he's going to push me okay
whoa so I'm going to turn that was it
that's enough so stay stay where you are
okay see where you are and if he pushes
you can see this one is slipping and
this one is slipping okay and it happens
from the circle then I just get out of
the way away he goes by he comes back in
and if I just go with my shoulders
Square you see we're still he's still
pushing so my shoulders have to do do
you see the
rotation right here
hip okay try to here just like when he
push when he pushes the tip of my sword
down and I yield you see I yield right
away I don't wait here as soon as he
pushes it it's moving okay so same thing
here moving he I I you want to work on
your sensitivity okay light touch light
touch and you're already deflecting
light touch light
touch
don't wait until you're like okay I'll
move or even here
no light touch light tou okay
[Music]
try
okay